so if you don't mind me asking what
ethnicity are you I'm actually Indian
really yeah which tribe um like the
country India yeah yeah the [ __ ]
should really change their name it's
offensive
they sing how do i unsynched my iphone
from my itunes i've got the rainbow we
looked at did you do some coding on it
or something hey I got this weird mole
if you take a look at it
oh yeah it's cool paint la parada el
autobus la parada de la bouche oh hey
you wanna hang out dude yeah
oh I have a friend's engagement this
weekend okay what about the next we're
gonna catch the wedding there's actually
two reception I'm free in six weeks
here we go
have you told your parents about me yet
do somethings your hair it looks great
it's been three years I was watching a
movie sorry with a friend
oh come on are you coming in again
she thinks they're together yeah what
happened what's wrong with lemon Oh fun
my mouth okay I thought this was a mild
Oh what you wanted I think this is
authentic models I'm so sorry about that
are you gonna finish that though I mean
no I mean I just don't you don't wanna
go to waste